let me ask you I mean there's a million
ways to ask this question I'm sure I'll
ask it about habitable worlds
let's just go to our own solar system
what can we learn about the planets and
moons
in our solar system that
might contain life whether it's Mars or
some of the moons of Jupiter and Saturn
what kind of characteristics because you
said it might not need to be Earth-like
what kind of characteristics might be
we'd be looking for
when we look for life it's hard to
Define even what life is
um but we can maybe do a better job in
defining the sorts of things that life
does and that provides
um some aspects to some Avenue for
looking for them
um any classically conventionally I
think we thought the way to look for
life was to look for oxygen oxygen is a
byproduct of fetch synthesis on this
planet we didn't always have it
certainly if you go back to the Arcane
period there was you know you have this
period called the Great oxidation event
where the Earth floods with oxygen for
the first time and starts to saturate
the oceans and then the atmosphere and
so that oxygen if we detect it on
another planet whether it be Mars Venus
or an exoplank whatever it is
um that was long thought to be evidence
for something doing photosynthesis
because if you took away all the plant
life on the earth the oxygen wouldn't
just hang around here it's a highly
reactive molecule it would oxidize
things and So within about a million
years you would probably lose all the
oxygen on planet Earth
so that was a conventionally how we
thought we could look for life and then
we start to realize that it's not so
simple because either might be other
things that life does apart from
photosynthesis certainly the vast
majority of the Earth's history had no
oxygen and yet there was living things
on it so that doesn't seem like a
complete test
and secondly could there be other things
that produce oxygen besides from Life
um a growing concern has been these
false positives in biosignature work and
so one example of that would be
photolysis that happens in the
atmosphere when ultraviolet right hits
the upper atmosphere can break up water
vapor the hydrogen splits off to the
oxygen the hydrogen is much lighter
Atomic species and so it can actually
Escape certainly plants like the Earth's
gravity that's why we don't have any
hydrogen or very little helium and so
that leaves you with the oxygen which
then oxidizes the surface and so there
could be a residual oxygen signature
just due to this photolysis process so
we've been trying to generalize and
um but certainly in recent years there's
been other suggestions things we could
look for in the solar system Beyond uh
nitrous oxide basically laughing gas is
a product of microbes
um that's something that we're starting
to get more interested in looking for
methane gas in combination with other
gases can be an important biosignature
uh phosphine as well and phosphine is
particularly relevant to the solar
system because there was a lot of
interest for Venus recently
um you may have heard that there was a
claim of a biosignature in Venus's
atmosphere I think it was like two years
ago now
and the the judge and jury is still out
on that
um there was a very provocative claim
and signature of a phosphine-like
spectral absorption
um but it could have also have been some
of the molecule in particular sulfur
dioxide
which is not a buyer signature so this
is a detection of a gas in the
atmosphere yeah Venus and and uh it
might be controversial on several
and dimensions so one had to interpret
that two is a thread gas and three is
this even the right detection is this is
there an error in the detection yeah I
mean how much do we believe that's
actually in the first place if you do
believe it does that necessarily mean
there's life there and
um what gives how can you have life in
the Venus's atmosphere in the first
place because that's you know been seen
as like a hell hole place for imagining
life but I guess the the counter that
has been that okay yes the surface is a
horrendous place to imagine life
thriving
um but as you go up in altitude the very
dense atmosphere means that there is a
cloud layer
um where the temperature and the
pressure become actually fairly similar
to the surface of the Earth and so it
may be there are microbes stirring
around in the clouds which are producing
phosphine
um at the moment this is fascinating
it's got a lot of us
reinvigorated about the prospects of
going back to Venus and doing another
mission there in fact there's now two
NASA missions Veritas and da Vinci which
are going to be going back and before
23rd to the 2030s
um and then we have a European Mission I
think that's slated now and even a
Chinese Mission might be coming along
the way as well so we might have
multiple missions going to Venus which
has long been overlooked I mean apart
from the Soviets there really has been
very little in the way of exploration of
Venus certainly as compared to Mars Mars
has enjoyed most of the activity from
NASA's Rovers and surveys and Mars is
certainly fascinating there's you know
this signature of methane that has been
seen there before
um again there the discussion is whether
that methane is a product of biology
which is possible something that happens
on the earth or whether it's some
geological process that we are yet to
fully understand could be a for example
a reservoir of methane that's trapped
under the surface and it's leaking out
seasonally so the nice thing about Venus
is if there's a giant living
civilization there it'll be airborne so
you can just fly through and collect
samples yeah with Mars and uh moons of
uh Saturn Jupiter you're gonna have to
dig
under to find the civilizations right
dead or living right and so yeah maybe
it's easier than for Venus because
suddenly you can imagine just a balloon
floating through the atmosphere
um the or a drone or something that
would have the capability of just
scooping up and sampling
um to dig under the surface of Mars is
maybe
feasible-ish with you know especially
with something like Starship that could
launch you know a huge Digger basically
to the surface and you could just
excavate away at the surface but for
something like Europa
um we really are still unclear about how
thick the ice layer is how you would
melt through that huge thick layer to
get to the ocean and then potentially
also discussions about contamination the
problem with looking for life in the
solar system which is different from
looking for life with exoplasts is that
you always run the risk of especially if
you visit there of introducing the life
yourself
right it's very difficult to completely
exterminate every single microbe and
Spore on the surface of your of your
Rover or the surface of your Lander and
so there's always a risk of introducing
something I mean
to some extent there is continuous
exchange of material between these
plants naturally on top of that as well
and now we're sort of accelerating that
process to some degree and so if you dig
into europa's surface which probably is
completely pristine it's very unlikely
there has been much exchange with the
outside world for its subsurface ocean
You Are For the First Time potentially
introducing bacterial spores into that
environment that may compete or may
introduce spurious signatures for the
life you're looking for and so
it's it's almost an ethical question as
to how to proceed with looking for life
on those subsurface oceans and I don't
think one we've really
have a good resolution for at this point
ethical assuming ethical in terms of
concern
for the
like for preserving life elsewhere not
like not to murder it as opposed to
Scientific one I mean we always worry
about a space virus right coming coming
here or you know some kind of external
source and we would be the source of
that potential contamination or the
other direction yeah I mean
they that you know the whatever whatever
survives in such harsh conditions might
be pretty good at uh
surviving in all conditions it might be
a little bit more resilient and robust
so I might actually take a ride on us
back home possibly I mean I'm sure I'm
sure that some people will be concerned
about that I think we would we would
hopefully have some containment uh
procedures as if we did sample return or
you mean you don't even really need a
sample return these days you can pretty
much sound like a little micro
laboratory to the other planet to deal
with experiments you know in situ and
then just send them back to your planet
the data and so I don't think this is
necessary that especially for a case
like that where you might have
contamination concerns that you have to
bring samples back
um although probably if you brought back
European Sushi it would probably sell
for quite a bit with the billionaires in
New York City
Sushi yeah
um I would love from an engineering
perspective just to see all the
different candidates and designs for
like the scooper for Venus and the
scooper for Europa and and Mars I
haven't really look deeply into how they
actually like the actual engineering of
collecting samples because that's the
engineering of that
is probably essential for not either
destroying life or or polluting it with
our own microbes and so on so that's an
interesting engineering challenge I
usually for Rovers and stuff focus on
the on the robot on the
sort of the mobility aspect of it on the
robotics the perception and the movement
and the planning and the control but
there's probably the scooper is probably
where the action is the microscopic
sample collection so basically you have
to first clean
your vehicle make sure it doesn't have
any Earth-like things on it and then you
have to put it into some kind of thing
that's perfectly sealed from the
environment so if we bring it back or we
analyze it it's not
um it's not going to bring anything else
uh external and yeah I don't know it
could be that would be an interesting
engineering design there yeah I mean
Curiosity has been uh leaving these
little pods on the surface quite
recently there's some neat photos you
can find online and it's they kind of
look like a lightsaber hilts which so
um that yeah to me I think I tweeted
something like uh you know this weapon
is your life like don't lose it
curiosity because it's just dumping
these little vials everywhere and it's
yeah it is scooping up these things and
the intention is that in the future
um there will be a sample return mission
that will come and pick these up
um but it's I mean the engineering
behind those things are so impressive
the thing that blows me away the most
has been The Landings
um especially I'm trained to be a pilot
at the moment so that's the sort of you
know watching Landings has become like
my I'll be on YouTube at the moment and
how not to do it how to do it with
different levels of conditions and
things but with the you know when we
think about landing on Mars Just the
light travel time effect means that
there's no possibility of a human
controlling that descent and so you have
to put all of your faith and your trust
in the computer code or the AI or
whatever it is that you've put on board
that thing to to make the correct
descent
um and so there's this famous uh period
called seven minutes of hell where
you're basically waiting for that light
travel time to come back to know whether
you're vehicle successfully landed on
the surface of not and during that
period you know in your mind
simultaneously that it is doing these
multi-stages of
um deploying its parachute deploying the
crane
activating its Jets to come down and
controlling its descent to the surface
and then the crane has to fly away so it
doesn't accidentally hit the Rover and
so there's a series of multi-stage
points where any any of them go wrong
you know the whole mission could could
go awry
um and so the fact that we are fairly
consistently able to build these
machines that can do this autonomously
is to me one of the most impressive acts
of engineering that NASA have achieved